[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 15 février voici
les titres
les permis seront actifs à l'été les
policiers municipaux de
voisins-le-bretonneux seront bientôt
armes et les six agents du service
suivant ce moment une formation la
commune rejoindra la poignée de villes
yvelinoise qui ont déjà franchi le pas
notamment à triel sur seine qui a équipé
ses effectifs depuis cinq ans jusqu'à
vendredi l'espace arnaud beltrame de
poissy accueille cette exposition elle a
été créée par d'anciens soldats français
blessés en afghanistan qui ont regroupé
textes et photos c'est à l'occasion du
20e anniversaire du premier engagement
de la france dans le pays d'asie
centrale et puis toute cette semaine tv
60,18 vous emmène dans les marchés des
yvelines véritable lieu de rencontres
d'histoires et de personnages hauts en
couleur premier numéro ce soir à
versailles au marché notre dame et lui
en 2018 comme le plus beau d'île de
france et on parle justement de
versailles avant de développer ses
titres avec cette information
officialisée il ya quelques minutes par
la fédération française de football la
demi finale de la coupe de france
versailles nice se jouera finalement à
nice coup d'envoi le 1er mars et non le
2 mars et ce sera à 21h le club
yvelinois de les recevoir la rencontre
mettait mais était à la recherche d'une
enceinte en ile de france pour
accueillir l'événement faute de stade
mont boron homologué elle les dirigeants
ont tout tenté jusqu'à aujourd'hui le
parc des princes le stade de france ou
encore le stade charléty sans succès
comme face à toulouse le match est donc
inversés et se disputera à l'alliance
rivera de nice il s'agira du troisième
déplacement d'affilée pour les yvelinois
qui devront faire tomber une équipe de
ligue 1 chez elle pour s'offrir une
finale au stade de france
également dans l'actualité les règles
qui évolue concernant le pass vaccinale
ce dès ce 15 février pour conserver son
qr codes valide la dose de rappel de
vaccin contre le collier de 10,9 devra
être réalisé au plus tard quatre mois
après la deuxième injection l'unique
injection pour ceux qui ont contracté le
virus avant le délai maximal jusqu'à
présent était de 7 jours aidés de sept
mois où les noms de sept jours elle est
le personnes ayant été positive après
deux doses de vaccin ou après une
injection est une infection sont
exemptés de rappel autre exception les
16 17 ans n'ont pas l'obligation
d'effectuer une troisième dose pour
conserver leur place vaccinale enfin dès
demain mercredi d'autres restrictions
qui sont levés les discothèques pourront
rouvrir les concerts debout et la
consommation aux comptoirs des bars
seront de nouveau autorisés
[Musique]
de plus en plus de villes font le choix
d'armes et leur police municipale selon
le ministère de l'intérieur 58% des
policiers municipaux sont un mets en
france les dernières communes en date
dans les yvelines a opté pour la mesure
ses voisins le bretonneux et on en parle
avec mon invité alexandra rosetti
bonsoir ans un jet de la maire de la
commune en 2016 vous décidiez d'équipé
votre police municipale de pistolets à
impulsion électrique
mais vous étiez plutôt défavorable à
l'époque
un dans l'idée parlant d' aller plus
loin et d'armes et vos agents municipaux
qu'est ce qui vous a fait changer d'avis
à l'époque vous disiez peut-être que ça
allait au delà de leur mission qu'est ce
qui a fait aujourd'hui vous allez
changer la vie alors oui effectivement à
l'époque on a faim on avait longuement
réfléchi avec mon équipe et on ne
voulait pas se substituer à la police
nationale dont c'est quand même le
premier rôle à la sécurité la police
municipale pour nous est une police de
prévention donc c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
on avait opté pour le pistolet à
impulsions électriques en pensant
surtout à leur propre sécurité
maintenant les choses ont évolué depuis
depuis cette époque le monde a changé la
ce et on voit bien qu'il ya pu y avoir
des difficultés dans des communes qui
d'habitude ne font pas parler d'elle et
donc on a également nous bien sûr
cheminée et évoluer et notre police
municipale et est très demandeuse d'être
armé et ce qui nous a permis aussi de
franchir le pas c'est là la confiance
qu'on a dans cette équipe c'est à dire
que voilà quand on quand on a des
policiers municipaux qu'on veut les
armées faut aussi être vraiment
certain qu ils sont capables de porter
une arme et l'équipe que nous avons
aujourd'hui effectivement a toute notre
confiance pour ça il s'agit d'anciens
policiers en d'anciennes personnes des
forces de l'ordre qui ont déjà eu des
contacts avec les armes à feu voilà
alors sur 6 4 ans déjà porter une arme à
feu soit parce qu'ils sont issus de la
jambe mouri soit parce qu'ils étaient
avant dans une police municipale qui
était armé et vous le disiez le contexte
a évolué il est différent aujourd'hui on
est forcé de penser à ces deux attentats
qui se sont déroulés sur le sol
yvelinois celui de magnanville en 2016
et de rambouillet l'année dernière qui
ont visé à chaque fois des policiers
sans oublier aussi l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit il ya une défiance et même
de la violence une grande violence
vis-à-vis de l'uniforme on voit même des
pompiers qui sont attaqués parfois dans
les yvelines voilà ça c'est l'idée les
uniformes un peu devenu une cible
mouvante donc je pense que pour nous
c'était très important de leur donner
les moyens de se protéger mais aussi de
protéger les habitants évidemment en
câbles des difficultés ceci dit ce n'est
pas eux d'intervenir si jamais il y
avait hélas à une attaque terroriste par
exemple cependant l'argument fort aussi
c'est que ils sont souvent les ce qu'on
appelle des primes aux intervenants s'il
se passe quelque chose c'est vrai que
c'est eux qui vont être les premiers sur
les lieux la nationale 2 arrivera
probablement juste derrière mais donc
donc c'est vrai que ça les met dans des
situations qui peuvent parfois être
délicate l'objectif on y mêle cdh avant
tout d'être préventif on précise juste
que pour l' arme à impulsion électrique
elle n'a été utilisé qu'une seule fois
il me semble un depuis 2016 est
effectivement moins je tiens à ce que la
police municipale reste dans son rôle de
prévention de dialogue avec les
habitants la verbalisation de ce qu'on
peut vivre au quotidien évidemment mais
voilà il ya quand même une inquiétude et
moi je tenais à ce qu'il se sente aussi
eu sécurisé et vous allez rejoindre une
poignée de villes qui ont déjà passé le
cap dans les yvelines triel-sur-seine
notamment qui a été l'une des premières
en 2010 est aujourd'hui la police
nationale fait souvent appel aux agents
municipaux triés loi pour leur venir en
aide le reportage de mathilde de france
elle est l'une des premières villes des
yvelines avoir doté ses policiers
municipaux d'armes létales pistolets à
impulsion électrique pistolet
semi-automatique et taser flashball
bâton télescopique ou latéral les agents
de triel-sur-seine dispose de toute la
panoplie on s'aperçoit et qui a pas
d'endroit ni ville voilà où il ne peut
rien se passer notamment voilà la
délinquance les itinérante on a des
accès aux grands passages comme la rue
paul doumer j'ai donc on ne sait jamais
avec qui on a affaire je crois qu'il est
vital il est nécessaire et vital il est
crucial même durée pour la pour la
commande à la sécurité déjà la première
sécurité des agents mais aussi des
administrés on est quand même bien
souvent les primo arrivants ou les
primes aux intervenants on les appelle
comme on veut les policiers municipaux
de triel-sur-seine travaille 7 jours sur
7 avec des plages horaires qui
s'étendent jusqu'à minuit en deux ans le
nombre d'agents a également quadruplé il
est passé de 3 à 13 ces mesures leur ont
permis d'intervenir plus régulièrement
la police municipale même partie
beaucoup plus à la sécurisation de la
commune puisque avant notre arrivée
avant l'arrivée de cette municipalité
les policiers municipaux faisait en
moyenne deux à trois interpellations par
an et là nous l'année dernière en 2021
on a fait plus de 30 pour avoir le droit
de porter une arme chaque policier suit
une formation avec une partie juridique
théorique pratique mais également
psychologique
le but d'avoir une arme à la ceinture
c'est pas dû utiliser l'armement c'est
pas de comment dire pardonnez moi je
n'aime pas cette expression là mais
c'est pas dur aux cowboys c'est d'avoir
un moyen ultime est de dernier recours
en fonction de la situation si on
l'utilisent c'est que quelqu'un va
mourir ou nous on va mourir ou une
tierce personne va mourir à
triel-sur-seine chaque agent doit signer
un registre pour signifier qu'il a
récupéré son arme dans les yvelines
plusieurs villes comme rambouillet ou
voisins le bretonneux ont décidé de
renforcer leur effectif et d'armes et
leur police municipale
selon le ministère de l'intérieur 58%
des policiers municipaux sont armés en
france on l'a vu alexandra rosetti dans
ce reportage or qui concerne une autre
commune triel sur seine mais tout est
bien cadré les policiers municipaux ont
suivi une formation et c'est le cas en
ce moment pour les policiers municipaux
de voisins-le-bretonneux question on
leur apprend dans ces formations alors
ils ont une formation de 45 heures sur
huit jours là effectivement certains des
policiers sont en train de la suivre qui
est dispensé bien sûr par des moniteurs
qui ont le qui sont spécialisés dans le
maniement des armes donc il ya
effectivement un volet juridique il faut
aussi qu'ils sachent ce qu'est ce que
c'est légitime défense par exemple et
puis ils ont également des manipulations
et des exercices de tirs dans
différentes situations pas juste debout
mais ça peut être dans statique en
mouvement accroupi voilà dans diverses
situations et à l'issue de cette
formation bien ils ont une évaluation il
doit faire un sans faute sur un parcours
et à l'issue de cela et bien ils ont
effectivement une évaluation psychique
c'est quand même aussi extrêmement
important et ensuite c'est le préfet qui
délivre les permis justement quelle est
la démarche pour une commune qui
souhaite armes et sa police municipale
d'une demande à faire auprès de la
préfecture tout à fait il faut faire une
demande motivée auprès de la préfecture
d'abord pour avoir l'autorisation de
lancer la formation donc là on a dû
acheter d'abord les armes pour qu'ils
puissent se former avec ces armes là et
puis on a une obligation je crois de
tirer 50 cartouches par an ensuite et
bien nous bien souvent les policiers
vont au delà les municipalités vont un
petit peu au-delà parce que nous nous ce
que nous souhaitons évidemment c'est que
nos policiers soient bien entraînés et
les bons réflexes au bon moment donc
c'est très cadrée et c'était une des
conditions
à laquelle auquel on voulait répondre
pour les armes et on voulait pas ce sera
une petite formation donc c'est quand
même pris très au sérieux et est donc
c'est plutôt rassurant donc il ya tout
un processus quand est ce que cette
mesure sera réellement effective un
voisin bretonneux alors le temps qu'on
les forme à rien a qui ont des
formations plus rapide que d'autres
parce que comme je voulais dit il était
déjà armé dans une police précédente
d'ici à l'été ils devraient tous
à voir l' arme létale s'ils ont bien sûr
répondu aux critères aient eu l'agrément
du préfet de la même façon si si ces
formations annuelles ne sont pas
respectées le préfet peut le retirer cet
agrément c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
à vie il faut vraiment avoir une
répétition tous les ans de la formation
et d'adaptation il ya eu un coup de 7000
euros il me semble un pour l'achat de 16
ans mais une subvention la région
ile-de-france tuer la région ile de
france a lancé un plan pour faciliter
l'armement des polices municipales dans
la région voilà ses coûts qu'elle est
l'autre sécurité le bouclier en sécurité
c'est qu'effectivement on est alors le
jeu ne pourrez plus vous dire par contre
j'ai pu le pourcentage en tête mais
c'est une aide précieuse c'est évident
ce qui nous coûte surtout cher parce que
7000 euros d'armes c'est pas une somme
mirobolante qui c'est de
l'investissement pour une commune c'est
absorbable c'est le sait la formation
qui pour le coup là prend beaucoup de
temps et est forcément un coût plus
important mais c'est indispensable
c'est à cet incontournable et nous irons
au delà même des effectivement des 50
cartouches demandé par an nous
n'hésiterons pas bien sûr accompagné nos
policiers merci alexandra rose et y est
je le rappelle maire de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également les dates
sont connues l'élection municipale
partielle de mantes-la-jolie se tiendra
le 15 mai et le 22 mai en cas de second
tour ce sera donc après les
présidentielles scrutin rendu nécessaire
après la démission du maire raphaël
cogner et de plusieurs conseillers
municipaux sous fond de tensions au sein
de la majorité mantaise l'édile sortant
sera d'ailleurs en lice face à jean-luc
santini candidats proches de pierre
bédier le président du département des
yvelines sont également déclaré
guillaume quévarec pour une liste
d'union de gauche et marc jammet membre
du parti communiste est depuis la
démission de raphaël cognait ses 6 10 et
les moeurs autre fidèle de pierre bédier
qui assure l'intérim à mantes la jolie
la maison de l'europe des yvelines a
célébré son 20e anniversaire c'était
lors d'une soirée organisée il ya
quelques jours alix campus de saint
germain en laye l'occasion de faire de
la pédagogie sur les institutions et sur
les actions menées au quotidien par
l'union européenne nicolas d'envoi des
élus locaux des universitaires et des
élèves du lycée international de saint
germain en laye tous sont venus célébrer
les 20 ans de la maison de l'europe des
yvelines une structure d'information sur
les politiques européennes
un outil essentiel sur les territoires
dans les institutions européennes avec
la maison de l'europe mais surtout avec
les saints trailer délecte s'est
confessée s'est rapproché de citoyennes
et citoyens voir un drapeau européen
près de sa maison auquel il peut faire
entendre sa voir écouter ce qu'ils ont
besoin d'information et participer dans
la vie européenne comme citoyens
européens qu il est important de faire
connaître l'europe c'est notre mission
de faire connaître l'europe ces
institutions ce que l'europe fait pour
les français au quotidien c'est quelque
chose que nous ignorons beaucoup encore
trop je trouve cet anniversaire
l'occasion de rappeler cette mission
d'information objectif démontrer
l'utilité de l'union européenne pour
certains gènes cette organisation a un
intérêt au niveau international la voix
de tous les pays compte dans cette
organisation est
aussi ça permet de donner une visibilité
à tous les pays et sur le tendon
internationale ça permet de ne pas avoir
de guerre pour moi et
aussi de pour les pays de l'union
pérenne de s'entraider concernant la
présence européenne dans la vie
quotidienne des français un travail
pédagogique est encore nécessaire enfin
dans ma vie quotidienne je trouve pas
trop que l'europe est une grande
importance après j'imagine que dans les
cadres des programmes comme erasmus ou
des choses comme ça ça peut
effectivement aider comme je suis
italienne et française je peux voyager
souvent en italie et je pense que ça
aide pas mal le fait qu'il ya une union
où voyagent pas mal dans l'europe et oui
c'est plus simple en 2022 38 maison de
l'europe sont en activité sur l'ensemble
du territoire français reportage avec la
voix de celles yaga tsongo
connaissez-vous le gnv biogée devait il
s'agit d'un gaz vers produit à partir de
la méthanisation des déchets organiques
en partenariat avec versailles grand
parc la commune de bulle vient
d'inaugurer deux stations délivrance ce
nouveau carburant et depuis et septembre
c'est deux entreprises en sont deux
entreprises qui peuvent rouler grâce à
ce procédé les précisions de mathilde
franco
depuis septembre 2021 la zone
d'activités économiques de bucca
accueilli deux nouvelles stations gnv
bio gnv gnv signifie gaz naturel
véhicule il représente une alternative
au tout pétrole produit à partir de
méthanisation de déchets organiques
agricoles de stations d'épuration ou de
biodéchets le gnv ou biogen v a quelques
avantages ce sont des avantages des
bénéfices environnementaux
et une fille - de nox également de
particules dioxydes de oxigen le carbone
- 2
de nuisances sonores on considère qu' à
peu près 50% de moins de bruit associé à
une motorisation ou gnv en partenariat
avec versailles grand parc et grdf les
entreprises nicollin et coved
spécialisée dans la collecte et le
traitement des déchets déploie des
véhicules qui roulent grâce à ce nouveau
carburant le retour il est plutôt
positif comme tout changement on a eu
des interrogations ces interrogations se
sont levés au fur et à mesure de notre
exploitation la mise en place s'est fait
de manière optimale tous les doutes
qu'on pouvait avoir sur notamment le
délai de remplissage l'autonomie des
camions
l'adaptation aussi à notre territoire
de ce type de carburant s'est fait
vraiment de manière optimale la mise en
place de ces nouvelles stations
permettra également à ces deux
entreprises de continuer leur activité
malgré l'instauration de la zone à
faible émission dans la métropole du
grand paris d'ici 2024 la motorisation
donc et le le carburant
biogen vais en fait et critères un don
qu'il satisfait la zone à faible
émission doit retrouver le grand paris
donc cela permet pour à la fois des
particuliers et des entreprises ou des
collectivités de pouvoir circuler
librement continuer à exercer leur
activité même dans un territoire soumis
aux conditions de les aider nous les
véhicules au gaz sont des critères 1
donc vont pouvoir avoir accès à cette
zone et du coup nous ça va nous
permettre de pouvoir continuer notre
activité en ile-de-france 1400 autobus
fonctionne grâce à ce gaz naturel et une
dizaine de nouvelles stations biogen v
sont prévues d'ici à la fin de l'année
il ya vingt ans la france s'engageait
dans le conflit armé en afghanistan
l'espace arnaud beltrame de poissy
propose de découvrir jusqu'à vendredi ce
qui a été le quotidien des soldats sur
place à ceux qui ont donné une part de
vie en afghanistan est une exposition
itinérante qui présente photos et textes
par des vétérans blessés de guerre en
reconstruction zoom avec céline charles
vingt ans après l'engagement des troupes
françaises en afghanistan une dizaine de
vétérans français blessés en opération
ont choisi de réunir leurs photos
personnelles pour en faire une
exposition il leur en donnait un sens
par l'écrit avec des textes intimes
associés à chaque photographie ce ne
sont pas des photos professionnelles ce
sont des photos réalisées par des
militaires en mission sur le terrain
pris à la volée et tous les cartels tous
les petits textes qui sont en dessous
c'est eux qui faisaient chaque auteur de
chaque photo
rédiger son texte aidés par
l'association escal l'exposition répond
à un travail de mémoire elle met en
avant les aspects humains et sublime le
pays pour en souligner la beauté malgré
la brutalité du contexte leur choix
délibéré était de dire
on parle de la beauté de ce pays de ce
qui nous a marqués et ce qui nous reste
20 ans après et bien c'est les paysages
les rencontres la richesse de ces
rencontres des la fraternité d'armes
quand on est rentré en 2001 soul et
aliments toutes les femmes étaient
habillées comme celle qui se trouve à
gauche et puis au cours des années qu'on
subit cette photo est prise en 2008 donc
sept ans après eh bien on commence à
voir des femmes sortir se promener
librement dans la ville sans être
accompagnés j'ai eu beaucoup d'action en
fait pour permettre aux femmes de
circuler librement de retourner à
l'école de faire des études d'avoir un
travail une exposition également
libératrice pour les vétérans blessés
qui on puisse se reconstruire grâce à ce
travail
c'est un travail de réhabilitation
des blessés par un projet qu'ils ont
monté et qu'ils ont réalisés par eux
mêmes au total c'est une soixantaine
d'oeuvres qui sont présentés
l'exposition est accessible à tout
public jusqu'au 18 février à l'espace
carnot beltrame à poissy et puis toute
cette semaine la rédaction de tv 60,18
vous emmène au marché découverte de
lieux emblématiques d'histoire unique
d'ambiance unique avec aussi des
personnages hauts en couleur premier
numéro ce soir au marché notre dame de
versailles inaugurée par le roi louis
xiv il ya plus de 300 ans et élu en 2018
plus beau marché d'île de france mickaël
et demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude vous y emmène
le soleil est à son zénith ce vendredi
sur la place du marché notre dame à
versailles à midi les allées encadrés
par les quatre quarts y grouille de
locaux et de touristes dans le carré de
la mare est une figure historique jean
jacques bouchard il est fier d'être
présent sur ce marché depuis 1966 on a
été classé quand même meilleur marché de
10 de la france donc
c'est un atout c'est c'est une clientèle
qui nous vient quand même des pourtours
de versailles qui vient de loin c'est un
c'est un marché qui date qui atteint
actuellement un peu près 350 ans mais
c'est le marché a été créé pour à
l'époque c'était un marché sait rien les
jambes des vendeurs
leurs produits et ça a été créé pour la
quand le château de versailles a été
construit à presque 82 ans jean jacques
ne compte pas raccrocher même s'il a
ralenti légèrement la cadence il se
plaît sur ce marché crespin louis xiv il
ya plus de 300 ans ne travaille plus par
nécessité je travaille par plaisir voilà
ce matin je me suis levé à 2 heures
je vais faire un geste sur les i
ci-après l' le matin je fais la journée
continue à marat deux heures mais je
m'arrête à 2 heures je rentre à la
maison aujourd'hui en fin d'après midi
cet habitant de buc adorent être présent
pour les centaines de clients qui
passent ici chaque semaine certains font
plus de 50 kilomètres pour venir le bord
voilà c'est dufrien qui nous fabriquons
nous mêmes versailles est une clientèle
très agréable c'est une clientèle fidèle
c'est une bonne clientèle je vois pas
pourquoi j'aurais quitté la région je me
plais bien versailles j'habite juste à
côté
en queue
comment ça je suis resté sur le si le
marché de versets c'est aussi la
rencontre des cultures des univers qui
se mélangent ici des spécialités turques
un peu plus loin des épices du monde et
dans cette allée un stand pas comme les
autres un triporteur italien aux
couleurs flashy tout droit sortie d'un
film s'est installé sur cette place de
versailles josé pettinato propose à ses
clients du café 100% italien partir de
6h30 avec un concept original c'est
c'est en fait en un volume à intégrer
l'esprit italien on peut dire avec
l'aide de ce triporteur à l'italienne
parce que c'est vraiment une un
triporteur iconique de l'italie
c'est un triporteur a fait qui a été
utilisé dans les années à 50 60 pour
passer les petites rues de l'italie donc
voilà on a on aménage et la partie
derrière en italie donc tout est fait en
italie on le fait faire en italie sur
sur-mesure et voilà donc on vend du café
et à l'aide de cette camionnette à
l'italien implanté depuis un an et demi
dans la cité royale cet italien de 30
ans originaire d'un petit village situé
en calabre ne regrette pas son choix et
je suis à versailles et d'adoption des
puits a maintenant plus de cinq ans
j'adore versa elle s'est
et du coup on en a on a décidé de se
lancer dans ce beau marché de vercel
parce que c'est un des meilleurs marchés
de de lisibilité on peut dire et je
pense même de l'île de france c'est une
clientèle de tout âge et ses magnifiques
parce que on installe tout un lien
social ce que ça nous a beaucoup manqué
on peut dire dans cette période de co
vide et maintenant voilà tout le monde
se retrouve ici autour d'un café on peut
dire ça une josé paix n'est pas le seul
nouveau commerçant de cette place du
marché à versailles sont plusieurs
chaque année à tenter l aventure depuis
début 2000 22 un nouvel espace inédit
s'est installé dans le carré de la marée
odette et tristan propose une cuisine
flexitariens entre les bouchers et
fromagers
du jamais vu sur le site on n'est pas à
part mais on vient peut-être compléter
plus tôt en offre de marché et a
beaucoup d'habitués qui font le marché
qu'ils ont c'est sam études mais ils
sont quand même content de voir que
l'offre nouvelle au marché ils sont
contents de voir que les halles et ses
radios nice aussi qui a de nouveau il ya
on apporte un peu de musique aussi donc
ils sont contents de venir le marché et
son ambiance qui était en béton qui est
déjà propriétaire d'un restaurant
flexitariens rue de satory à versailles
depuis 2015 le duo à exporter son
savoir-faire sur le marché en proposant
une offre différente et dans l'air du
temps ici on mange équilibré et sur le
pouce on a des cookies les brownies
mais les mots fine fait avec nôtre
granola donc sucrés et salés banoun
havrais donne aussi des pâtisseries
salées avec des tartes végétarienne des
impôts nadal un peu d'inspiration
libanaise n'avait de ce mec des épinards
des fêtards en offre chaude donc on a
toujours un d'allouer un curé de légumes
aujourd'hui au nom d'al des lentilles
blondes avec des légumes saison
chou-fleur et pata 12 de falafel des
carottes avec des pesto sauce mayo
confère à ces noix de cajou et
des épices on a donc la volaille et
d'oeufs sont bons et on peut composer
des aciers du marché qui vient toujours
donc avec une protéine un accompagnement
et des légumes au choix un concept
novateur qui complète une offre
historique et traditionnel le marché
notre-dame de versailles se renouvelle
sans cesse depuis sa création et n'a pas
fini de surprendre ses visiteurs dans
les prochaines décennies chien
le prochain numéro à suivre dès demain
dans le journal sur tv 60,18 voilà c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant ne manquez pas
le 7-8 culture présentée par ces yaga
tsongo belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]